match did you watch Glee Glee have you
did you watch Glee before yeah I watched
the first thing did you like Leigh I did
what I was like straight out of no
school so me all middle school kids
likely like I was young so like who's
Jesus I liked it you don't got to defend
you liking Glee I miss asking if you
liked it
yeah I was in middle school okay I don't
know what I'm [ __ ] up being
interrogated I was asking if you like
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah I like Lee yo for what so
what was it go home and I'm like so
tired from work let's do that I'm tired
at work I do this tired defending myself
and conversations with you is just so
exhausting you don't have to defend
yourself though I know I get it we could
you just just take my answer for what it
is
okay fine you're right she's gotta say
how you feel yes I watched this [ __ ]
loser look at this one seven seven seven
oh my god it looks like the seven seven
five before my old ass grandma oh it's a
grandma grandma grandma wasn't me
the passenger love to be a rapist you
need some sleep
I do okay you look terrible
thank you so much I've heard that for me
about seven times a day the parts of
this job is that I get to tie buses he
looks like [ __ ] no the person of this
job to handle this for days and you're
still fired first of all my grandma
passed away first of all second of all
blow second of all my freaking tire
popped on the freeway
third of all your tire magically popped
you know like that [ __ ] you think I
don't like sit on the free for three
hours late first look at that to cut
your boss like you taught the HR yeah
okay here we go
yeah so what happened mr. Wong first of
all you look I can't take you seriously
right now your eyes are so blue to
chapped lips I know I haven't waxed yet
I'm letting him grow up [ __ ] French
as hell I think they're wax up no no I
went to the ladies with them this long
and she said Dushan
that's too short I just want to remove
one way or another and I shouldn't like
baby grass dude what about what about
that thing that product were it's like
it's like a robotic tweezer
would never use it down there oh yeah
there's way too much down there yeah it
would be a wonder why [ __ ] [ __ ]
why say stuff like that good cuz you'll
don't you wax her armpits I don't wash
my armpits what the [ __ ]
or tweeze them shayzon i trimmed them I
trimmed them because better cuz Morel
doesn't like it that's so weird
you I've seen your armpits with like no
hair before no this is there's hair
there but you tweeze it real short then
I don't tweeze them why you stared at my
armpits ho are you armpit detective what
the [ __ ] does he wear tank tops [ __ ]
dick Tracey over here hey you see those
over there I'm not sure of his tweezer
shaved microscope you were taking